dude your Instagram is uh you do people
don't know you do some of the best
bachelor coverage I know on IG man it's
not helping my straight case no well
actually the funny thing was I remember
when you invited me over to watch The
Bachelor oh yes all right only had a
block and then yeah no we had a blast
definitely you also I had to sit on the
sofa you sat behind a chair I didn't
want anything I was making any moves oh
except for murder baby and you're like
why do I need to run I'm in a penny wise
cost yeah it's like what why no I always
buy cuz my [ __ ] back I can sit on
that couch well dude didn't don't let
have other people sit on it in fronting
like I should tell people listen yeah
just tell him a little me probably won't
get killed yeah cuz I didn't know you're
that good that's right no it was just
like all right and I I was I was like
one of those creepy kids the movies at
walks with my knees go the wrong way and
I'm like don't mind me you're like what
the [ __ ] you know if I see a movie first
I never see scary movies if I see like a
little girl in a dress who's like 10 and
she has black hair in her face and she
walks with her knees go the wrong way
the joints I'm out there's a lot of
[ __ ] chance I'm seeing that movie oh
she's from outside of the city limits do
we got a question right here we have a
question hmm how does this happen
they sent a man we let him know they
were gonna come in yesterday oh well we
need headphones for this on it yeah okay
go ahead
it's complicated show the debate is a
fan of The Bachelor and my question for
him is if you could change the format
and be the new Chris Harrison mix things
up what would you do to change it what
was her name Shelby she didn't say it
she'll be a beautiful of age girl tip
she's very calm and her question yeah it
wasn't fanning out which I sort of
wanted I wanted her to go oh my god I
came to think of my questions David's
face yeah I'm so nervous so nervous the
tape fost that he might see one yeah so
the bachelor I do like what do you like
them - this stupidity of I don't yeah
you know it's got cute girls I just find
him make fun of everyone oh yeah that's
why I like it too actually and they and
every girl knows about it so if you talk
about they have something talk about
something common and they're all single
girls and 29 of them are losing so you
go well you're gonna run into them at
Pizza Hut no I well you don't know
Hawaii friend so at least it's not like
you're creeping on some married show
yeah look at all these hot married girls
so it's just more for comedy and fodder
but I think I don't know what I would
change cuz they obviously have it wired
I do like this new situation which you
wouldn't know what there's a guy named
Tyler he's like I'm not going this guy's
too good-looking he's on The Bachelor
he's vying for the one girl Hannah I
think he's gonna win it all cuz she's
good-looking but he's a he's a bit of a
dud mm-hmm but it's never stopped any
guy from getting laid right so he
doesn't get picked he's the third runner
so they go he's gonna be the next
Bachelor and then in this new crazy
world gigi hadid
says this guy is hot Wow and so now
they're dating now they're dating no and
guess what not only dating they're
dating every second of every day you
know couples are like velcro monkeys
like Shoop like just together right away
like magnets he went to her grandma's
funeral with the programís you know whoa
whoa whoa so that's very Native American
- my thing is first of all these guys
that have so much free time so a girl
likes you you fly to New York or
whatever I don't worry lives and you
don't leave her [ __ ] sight do you have
one thing to do in the last six weeks
you've been with her a haircut a dentist
appointment yeah I have [ __ ] natives
remember something you left somewhere
yeah you can go hey I can see this
afternoon this morning got a couple
things I gotta work out what no he has
24 hours a [ __ ] day obviously not a
job yeah they never have jobs they
always quit the job to go on back to
people in the bathroom yeah this is
Stedman this is like a new Stedman yeah
and look at he's hot though when I left
now he is very handsome I was good at
that funeral look at him he could have
yeah he almost wished the grandmother
was a lot to get a good look at him he
said the grandma was in the coffin and
he and he saw the roses he goes when's
she gonna give him out cuz he didn't
know where nobody else there's no
anything else I get one I'm gonna reject
it wow this is intense there you go dude
he is ripped is it do you think men are
more handsome since you've gotten older
or when you
I didn't know what good-looking guys
were growing up like I couldn't tell now
when you get all the data of what girls
like you can start to say oh this guy's
guys handsome I never look from the well
I never look waist down though you don't
do that I don't know I don't yeah I
don't look at this picture of this man
but I will only like my eyes can't even
I never knew that part because the girl
I went out with said uh about two years
ago she goes I saw Harry Styles and then
she goes look at this picture when I
alright he's in a suit and she just
wears this dick I go what do you mean
just look where his dick is you can't
even see it sticking out I go
why does dick be popping out of his
pants shoes I all I do is look at guys
dicks all day in their pants I go
[ __ ] really I go no one my dicks not
do anything in the day like yeah I'm
good I'm getting screwed on that deal
because I don't want to walk on slapping
together a half a rod just it so some
chick might look for it and you know I'm
doing that before I'll sneak off for I
go in a busy room and just kind of shake
it a little maybe if there's some [ __ ]
going on like it's like you're mixing a
[ __ ] milkshake we don't know if I'm
walking out of the Emmys I might get a
couple cc's of plasma [ __ ] [ __ ]
slamming it in the door back yeah I
heard one time I was on this cruise ship
and I was trying to get an erection this
girl was a real [ __ ] land animal you
know and I literally was like whacking
my wiener against the wall trying to get
blood into oh god I still remember that
I'm the words in India I'm like a
one-trick pony like that's everyone
thinks I'm like whatever I don't know
what they think but where do you think
here you definitely just Casanova before
we get in that though I want to talk a
little bit more what else would you do
about the bats or anything else cuz I
know me on that question I could almost
see Harrison first of all we'll never
give the job up he is low-key but he's
seeing for these women
oh I mean and they they have nothing to
an island but sneak in his room yeah
he's on the island too so oh he's I mean
it is boring because you know they pull
him out for three minutes a day and he
has to wear a suit knowledge [ __ ] but I
wonder if he's allowed to mingle and
hang out it must be rule that he gets
all their numbers I mean he's got all
their IDs he's DMing up a frenzy
I don't think he's married and then he
goes the bachelor Island then he does it
there
he came on her show and he was cool he's
a
got his cool animal copy were you on the
show with him he was awesome was it me
you and Kaley Cuoco no what show were
you one who was was she divorced again
yet or no no they don't live together
though now that I like
isn't that interesting did you enjoy
that clip well you really would have
enjoyed it if he was watching on a TCL
TV TCL is America's fastest growing TV
brand it's so fast it's the Carl Lewis
of television brands it's that Florence
Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its 5th anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com